thank you
um
again
okay um so real pleasure to introduce
the agent Choi who's our next speaker
from University of Washington uh she
works on NLP and it's
um is
think there's a is a perfect
follower to insults talk about sports
the agents also McCarter fellow and as a
great speaker so looking forward to your
talk
okay thank you um so yeah I'm excited to
talk about what might be possible and
not possible with the Sparks of AGI
especially what may be seemingly
impossible but possible and vice versa
so along that direction let's buy
started by imagining a feature that may
or may not happen so near 2050 may not
even happen if we solve everything and
you know there's nothing to do other
than going to the beach but if we were
to still have it uh what would that be
like
um maybe you know we burnt uh too many
GPU hours and we have to move to
metaverse because of the climate change
nobody travels anymore or we had to even
move to Mars so the venue is now more so
for the first time in 2015 and in that
conference uh would you be excited to
see more fuchsia engineering
what happens with the scaling laws at
that time and whatever applications
would we work on uh I really wish a
parental Plumbing is one of the hardest
challenge for AGI so we'll see what
happens with that
um maybe you know AI starts writing
papers so much so that um it will be
best to human paper award to separate
from best paper awards given to you know
human being the first author of the
paper and maybe there will be panels
among Chachi PT and humans
um and perhaps uh in that conference uh
in fact Chachi PT writes the paper and
also reviews the paper and you let both
of them to speak to each other for
rebuttal period on behalf of you
diffusion generates your slide the back
and then Nerf can present your talk and
then why bother going to any of the talk
because Church apt can summarize that
talk so maybe all of this is a complete
nonsense
um if quantum Computing does happen and
now we have this qpt with the perplexity
near one at which point again we might
just go to the beach but
um you know it's also possible that we
might still be debating whether Asia is
around the corner or not and whether we
solved a dog level embodied AI or not
and the weather compositionality really
uh is a thing so
um yeah having said all this nonsense so
this talk is going to be first about the
possible impossibilities and then vice
versa and then I'll discusses some
paradoxes that we can think about
his climber though uh I'm gonna end up
asking more questions than being able to
provide good answers so please don't
expect too much so for the
impossibilities
um it seems like so Asia might be just
around the corner
um and uh everything seems so possible
and in that context is there anything
really impossible and we feel like uh
scaling might be all you need and so
forth so on one hand we feel like we're
so close to AGI but on the other hand as
intad also alluded in his talk there are
many things that we don't yet understand
and perhaps it's a little bit similar to
what happened with the physics so uh
1878 there was this student Max Planck
who considered the two major in physics
and the professor Philip Von Jolie
recommended not because in that field at
that time almost everything looked
almost already solved and All That
Remains is to feel a few unimportant
holes and so then the student said I
don't wish to discover new things I only
want to understand the
non-fundamentals and he went ahead and
created this entire New Field the
quantum physics so since then there are
a lot of you know things that are weird
uh almost counter-intuitive at least for
uh people outside you know physics
proper
such as dark matter you know
Schrodinger's cat that may be both alive
and dead simultaneously and wave
particle duality these are all
conceptually quite strange things to
learn about and I do wonder whether
there may be something like that going
on in the way that we understand or
don't understand the intelligence in the
way that we don't understand or
understand Transformers and so forth and
there may be some interesting
counter-intuitive things that we can
investigate further
and there are many questions one could
ask I could throw questions like can HR
happen with or without embodiment uh
whether rlhf can really uh fully align
llms to factuality or not but I don't
have any answers to this I just touch
vaguely on the compositionality in this
stuff
so this talk uh is going to be based on
this paper on archive
um it so happens that the first five
others quarters are all women we didn't
plan for this
um but maybe that was uh fate but anyhow
so the question is does uh Sparks of AGI
AKA gpt4 or my favorite language models
can do multiplication or not so we ask
and actually it kind of looks correct
you know but it's a little bit Incorrect
and it's the first digit is correct and
the last decision by the usually the
first digit last digits are correct
um so but you know I'm told that you you
have to ask it to think step by step
right so we do that and there's a
different number now but it's also
slightly incorrect
uh so if you ask this systematically
what happens is that gpt4 can do three
digit by three digit multiplication
about sixty percent good and
um you know depending on how you look at
it this is like mind the blue and good
or uh it's a little bit worse than you
may have expected
what's your guess for four by four digit
multiplication
oh how how did we do this so that we
actually we can increase the number I'll
show you that if you do a scratch Pad
you know more like you know really uh
allowing it to think out loud the
channel without reasoning it does much
better I'll show you the number but
without doing that just like uh asking
directly
uh it turns out four percent accurate
for four by four and zero percent for
five by five digit multiplication Again
by humans I cannot do this either so
maybe you know we can justify that it's
okay uh we're asking too much
so I know you know a lot of you probably
think like why do we even care about
multiplication so in this paper we
actually also look at dynamic
programming problems and Einstein Falls
a logic problem but in this talk I'm
gonna just focus on multiplication
because a it doesn't require
compositional multi-sub reasoning B it's
just easy for us to discuss and think
about
um and in some sense I'm just curious
especially seeing how amazing gpt4 is
with language proficiency and being able
to compose text you know we're much much
better than what I'm capable of it's
just a fascinating uh to understand
where the boundaries are so in that
sense
multiplication might be interesting but
that's that never in my life did I
imagine that one day I would actually
write a paper focusing on multiplication
so much but let alone that some other
people like it too so Kevin Murphy said
he liked the paper despite the fact that
it's just about multiplication by and
large so
uh here's another question but maybe you
know gpt4 didn't see enough of
multiplication examples so what happens
if we do supervised training so we did
we cannot do gpt4 scale supervise the
training because the API is not provided
by open AI but gpt3 DaVinci model does
have API uh that you can pay for to to
do supervised training so we train gpt3
DaVinci size
with 1.8 million or 80 of that example
so 1.8 million examples include all
these combinations of um let's see one
by one digit two by one digit two by two
digits three by one digit three by two
up to four by two and then we randomly
split that into 80 training and ten
percent 10 for the event Test
watching your guess is that how well
would this go this is supervised
training on really a lot of examples
let's just say like a show of the hands
how many of you think this seems like
Transformers should be able to do
there's a lot of examples I mean you
should be able to do in the sense how
good though
might include uh any of these numbers
like four by one or four by two
um four by one is probably trivial so
it's like uh it's a in in distribution
test case right now
so we actually didn't know like what to
think of
um or at least you know I felt like on
one hand I can believe that this must be
doable on the other hand I don't know
but anyway so it's actually not very
easy to train this uh even uh to do well
on the in domain cases
um of course out of a domain case it
gets even worse
so but then you know we thought oh maybe
this is because of tokenization issue
because uh it may not know the number
boundaries correctly so what if we train
gpt2 from scratch so we cannot do by the
way academics don't have the enough gpus
to train gpt3 scale model from
scratchable we can do GPT to excel so
let's just say don't worry about English
words or any worse when you worry about
tokens that are numbers so you we only
have a 10 tokens then what would happen
do you think this is trainable or not
just a number of multiplication so I
wasn't sure what to expect personally
maybe some of you like shake their hands
and this should be impossible so it
turns out uh it's very hard to train gbt
to excel only using pen tokens
it's only like 10 accurate so there's
something interesting about how
pre-trained language models that are the
same language those uh seem to perform
better despite the fact that
tokenization may have not been optimal
for them yes in all these examples are
you trying to get the answer immediately
after the prompt for the time being yes
later I will show you the other case as
well
because I you know like as we all know
China we thought uh is important so
anyway the tokenization in itself may
not be the issue so okay uh you wanted
to see this scratch Pad so we tried many
different scratcher pads the best we
could uh and it turns out
with the scratchet pad the gpt4 does do
so much better so on three by three
digit it's 92 percent good it's not
perfect yet but it's getting so much
better for sure so but
now the question is does that generalize
to a slightly longer digit and turns out
not really uh accuracy decreases down to
four percent on the longer digit I mean
you know you can imagine that this
should do worse but not like that bad
it's not I don't think these results are
all that obvious to to guess
um so then uh you might if you're a
skeptic then I you have to do supervisor
training on that
um but actually before showing you that
I wanted to share a bit of this
community reaction to this empirical
results because you know we do see
messages like
um
yeah Transformers absolutely can learn
through multi-step algorithms in context
and generalized arbitrary problem sizes
uh what's going on and you know here's
one such example that shows how to teach
algorithmic reasoning using in context
uh prompt engineering so we open the
paper and it turns out their results are
similar to ours in some sense in that
um you know from here they go to here
for subtraction
for multiplication they have they appear
to have a bigger jump uh so first of all
it's not 100 you're not going to be very
impressed if I tell you I came to
multiplication 80 good
uh but moreover this multiplication
there's a fine line so they also found
that gpt4 is not very good if you go
beyond the three digit so what they do
is they dissect a longer digit down to
three by three or less and then uh sum
them up so it's not quite the same as
actually being able to do four by four
in one go so there's some dissection
that's required but I mean maybe that's
all you know correct way of doing it in
the end but for the purpose of
understanding what is possible and not
possible uh we found at least I was
puzzled or surprised even that the
numbers are lower than uh what I would
have anticipated considering how amazing
it is with language-based generalization
so then we decided okay maybe we should
the supervised training with the scratch
pad on gpt3 and just curious you know
what happens if you we do do that so
uh but it's very expensive
uh if you want to do a five by five
digit this is oh we don't have that kind
of money I can barely spend maybe that
much so uh I'm sure so that's why we
tried out of curiosity and it does
really work much better as you may have
expected it's like uh
96 percent accuracy on in distribution
but then it doesn't generalize very well
on out of the domain I mean meaning here
in a longer digit multiplication
oh scratch Pad is um
[Music]
to the chain of a thought but more
version
yeah this kind of stuff showing exactly
how to do step-by-step reasoning as a
few short examples that we provide and
the thing is this example can become a
bit too long for longer digit so just
declare but in this slide uh in context
example is the same as the query but
with one number on by one was that
always the case or is this just
something that's in the slide do you see
what I mean like the example that you're
that you're so the example you're
providing in context is 999
oh no this is not this is uh just by
chance we we do a randomly okay
right so uh where was I
uh yeah so why does this happen it's
curious
[Music]
um
anyhow so you know we were after
archiving this paper we also uh uh
wondered about kurokin you know what
about broken first of all uh who knows
what happens if you keep paying open AI
more money
but to the extent we were willing to pay
uh we didn't see that happening yet and
again you know this is like a really
interesting question and this is for me
that how do we know whether Brooklyn was
going to happen but didn't happen versus
it's not going to happen at all and if
so why like why multiplication is
fundamentally harder than language
questions I mean I have a speculation
about that but
that aside so
we founded that in general there's some
what appears to be fundamental limits to
uh at least multiplication or some
dynamic programming algorithm like
problems that we experimented with
um I can give you a little bit more
insight about what sort of Errors uh
these models I mean Transformers make by
the way so we can consider
multiplication through a computation
graph so when you do even as simple as
two by one digit multiplication uh what
you do is
um you know you do multiplication of two
numbers and then story somewhere and
then you have to add make sure that you
carry a digit correctly if you need to
carry anything and then finally arrive
at this and the benefit of drawing this
computation graph is that we can
actually Trace back what exactly was
training in the training data versus in
the test data so unlike language
problems in which I may or may not have
depending on which language model you
want to dissect I may not have direct
access to their training data one can
only speculate in this case we can
actually have full access to the
training data at least you know if we
are training from scratch so
that helps and we found that in general
uh the computation graph have different
width and depth of course and the
performance is you know exactly
proportional to the complexity of uh
that graph so you know if you multiply a
thousand with two thousand for example
that's easy because you're not actually
doing multi-step reasoning you're just
doing copy and paste of numbers based on
memorized uh shortcut patterns so we
found that
um it's almost like when multiplication
happens
uh the Transformers may not be doing the
true entire uh multi-step reasoning
rather recognition of the sub graph that
was repeated so many times on the
training data and then be able to invoke
that for the final answer so we have
lots of graph demonstrating how many
times certain subgraph happens has to do
with that portion of computation being
actually correct
um I mean maybe humans also do some of
the multiplication actually this way so
who knows I think I'm gonna skip this
error type
accounts more details than you want to
see I just mentioned that in the paper
we also have this appendix
where we try to sketch out a theory or
proof that maybe by Design uh there's
gonna be a rapid Decay with increased
compositional depth and in fact some
such I mean many previous papers sort of
demonstrated that in in different ways
about by and large their prior work was
based on weaker language models as gpt2
so then you know people wonder whether
there's something so magical
different about the larger Scale Models
like gpt4 such that some capabilities
really truly emerge and you know none of
this may or may not be uh
relevant anymore so at least empirically
we wanted to see whether we can push the
boundary further although you know we
couldn't afford more GPU compute so who
knows what happened is if somebody is
willing to push this further off but
anyway yeah
you ask the question
uh give me an approximate answer to this
slides this you know four digit times
four digit or five yeah which is the new
math number yeah yeah so
it's already doing approximation on all
your digits and the last digit better
because usually those are the places
where you and also it notice like how
many pages you actually need for the
correct answer so that much of
approximation seems to work but within
the
comprehensible analysis so for example
when you get the wrong answer could you
know was it was it really just saying
okay let's um
it would probably do better yeah
yeah yeah I
I imagine that uh it will do better and
of course you know you give calculator
it's going to do way better we all know
that
um and maybe that's exactly the point
though and then the Curious question is
is it multiplication just like one where
the case or are there any other aspects
of
um language understanding or even common
sense and by I I come back to this
Common Sense problem later
um I'm gonna make a weird analogy to
Common Sense later but for now
um you know it's a little bit uh maybe
you know uh you might wonder are these
just weird uh edge cases and it doesn't
really matter for other kinds of
language based problems or not so I just
wanted to throw that question I don't
know the answer for sure
um but it is curious why multiplication
is harder uh and are there other
compositional tests so it turns out so
my colleague Ashish at AI too and also
real Mario he's a PhD student at Europe
University I've been thinking about this
from uh theoretical perspective that
assumes uh that you know maybe
Transformers has at most look and
precision so by the way if your
Transformers are infinitely precise then
it's a turing complete but you know in
reality it's not infinitely precise it
has either finite Precision or maybe
variable length of precision but in any
case they assume for the purpose of the
theory improving that uh it's uh at most
log and where n is the length of the
context
and so assuming that you know the
weights are perfect Etc uh they then
look at different complexity class
and conclude that uh if you do without
Channel without reasoning so it's either
encoder only or decoder only but without
allowing that to the channel without
reasoning then uh it may be like inside
this tc0 class that doesn't include many
seemingly uh simple enough a polytime
problems as graph connectivity linear
inequality but in their follow-up work
that might be uh still uh they might
come out soon but they also consider
General reasoning and not surprisingly
it does it does uh enhance the
capability a lot so that to the point of
um
maybe a lot of these are more possible
with the channel without reasoning
whether it's planning as Intel mentioned
earlier also is outside
what may be feasible so
um this is sort of like upper boundary
results as I understand and maybe
there's more to think about uh but
um based on their speculation it's not
very clear what a multiplication should
have been possible but we just couldn't
train him well enough or there's some
other tighter theoretical bound around
that as well so again I'm just asking
more questions about being able to
provide answers but that was a living
negative perhaps so let's talk about
something more positive sorry yeah I'm
confused I mean multiplication isn't you
know nc1 and even in tc0 right so if
we're specifically interested in
multiplication than it is in these very
little classes no she had a bit of
limits on number of bits uh yeah but
it's in uh oh
um okay so so now we're going to be
plugging in the specific numbers
and be saying that it's not enough but I
mean but I mean the size of the models
are you know you know there are billions
of neurons that you know if we're
talking about
a large language the number of uh tokens
the size of the contact stand for the
size of the architecture actually I was
curious about that too because it
obviously in our experiment the larger
models are more capable and it seems
that at least you know
their Theory doesn't touch on the size
of the models yet yeah that's that's one
more point in fact is we have more than
bondedly many layers yeah we have more
like log many layers but in real
Transformers and a lot Precision seems
too weak
I feel like uh some assumptions may or
may not be immediately relevant for the
empirical uh phenomena that we we face
but I'm hoping that similar to people
figure something out here and no I mean
I mean they're clearly there are
problems or we could explain that you
know llm's failure by saying it
literally cannot represent this
algorithm
it's just that multiplying integers is
not one of them
[Music]
anyhow let's talk about something more
past positive so now the next step is
about you know what may seem just uh
impossible but might be possible
So speaking of
what may seem impossible when the Sam
automat was asked by Rajan Ananda
earlier this year how can Indian
startups create Foundation models for
India he said it's hopeless
and first of all
um yeah I mean there's some truth to it
and that's how we feel in Academia too
right it's a hopeless without much
compute I hope that it doesn't
discourage Indian startups and I hope it
doesn't discourage academics to think
about what else can we do
um but in that sense the following
question will look impossible or
hopeless so let's just say hopeless
distillation or impossible distillation
so here what we try to do
is just like a bit of a thought
experiment so right now as we all know
the winning recipe is Extreme scale
pre-training followed by RL HF at scale
so you do that you get amazing results
but what if I ask the following question
what if I start with the gpt2
which is low quality small model and
then somehow bake high quality small
model I don't know how that's possible
but just for now let's hypothesize that
hypothetically
and then compete with gpt3 which is
orders of magnitudes larger
so this do you agree this looks
impossible
Okay so
how is that even possible when imitating
from proprietary llms are supposedly
hopeless as well so there's this paper
from Berkeley here at Berkeley that says
the you know the first promise of
imitating proper proprietary llms and
you know the gist of it is that
um for the purpose of a general purpose
building general purpose uh models uh
just distilling the knowledge from
larger models may not be enough
the larger models are just better period
it might also be that there's something
about a particular task selection that
the paper explorer that that is a little
bit more susceptible to these sort of
like small models looking just
completely out of the lake but then
there are other papers out there uh even
including you know in touch talk earlier
that shows well you could build a
smaller model with you know better data
or better something so that you at least
have a task specific model that is
competitive against the larger
counterpart so that's the part that I'm
going to explore in this part of the
talk in particular
we're going to try to do uh learning to
abstract uh in the sentences
summarization sense so uh I just like
personally I'm fascinated by the fact
that humans are so much better at
abstracting away what we learn and read
what is you know gpt4 is able to just
attend to humongous number of tokens uh
in one go like I nobody can do that in
this room I'm pretty sure uh but there's
something about human intelligence that
genuinely is about abstracting away
almost right away so in essence we were
excited to think about this
summarization problem
in particular the way that we're gonna
frame our challenge is the following
we're gonna We're Not Gonna rely on
Extreme scale pre-training we're not
going to rely on RL HFS scale we're not
going to rely on supervised uh data set
for summarization either and by the way
if you are in the NLP field
summarization requires either supervisor
training data at scale or other LHS in
fact that's the PPO the original
algorithm I believe was tried for
summarization task to begin with so uh
either you know summarization works well
through lhfs at scale or you know
supervised data set gpt4 is really good
at summarization and I don't know
whether it's coming I'm assuming that's
coming from some mix between these two
not only just the pre-training scale I
don't know whether it actually that's
another question like if you don't do
any of this but only the extreme scale
pre-training those uh language
capabilities like summarization actually
emerge where is it only the byproduct of
this other other steps but anyhow so for
now without any of that
uh how do we even go anywhere so the key
idea is that AI is as good as the data
that it was trained on in fact that's
sort of like the recipe behind the uh
you know the textbook is all you need
experiments that inter demonstrated
except we're not even going to distill
from large model at all we're not going
to rely on supervised human written data
we're not going to rely on gpt3
distillation either we are only going to
stick with the gpt2
yeah did I convince you that this looks
impossible enough
how many of you think this sounds
impossible actually I'm kind of curious
and
this seems a reasonably impossible
or this seems like uh now I mean like
probably I'm telling a story that is
possible right so you're going to use
what size model now
so it's less than a billion yeah 1.5
billion the largest one yeah there's no
point in the pipeline uses any gpd30
gpd4
we are going to
putting on the other pipeline involved
UC but just like small yeah so we draw
from our earlier exploration but this
previous work where we started with the
general language model to build the
common sense model was distilling from
GPT Theory so we asked the gpt3 uh and
that's by the way what intended as well
to generate some good text to book style
Common Sense uh factoids that we
organize into this uh Knowledge Graph
and then fine tune smaller gpt2 or Bart
then you get a smaller model that's
quite competitive against the original
teacher model actually in our case it
was doing better than gpt3 in the end
but
I kind of didn't like the fact that
we're relying on the larger model for
the teacher so we wanted to see whether
we can get rid of it in at least for
some task
um as a starting point so what we are
going to do is we start with the gpt2
which is so low quality if you look at
the output of it it just looks so
hopeless I I go back to this in a bit
but our goal is somehow squeeze out high
quality task specific data set then the
rest will be uh Breezy it's gonna be a
stress word because we can do
straightforward supervised trend so if
you try to use gpt2 to summarize then
what happens is that after trying so
many nothing is good like zero percent
is good so we ask a summarize and it
says a lot of random things so after
trying say hundreds of times
zero is good zero
this shouldn't be surprising even like
okay this is uh guaranteed to be bad
so then what we do is we first try the
lexicolic constrain the decoding using
our prior work called the neurological
coding
um
and so we identify some keywords uh and
then see whether we could ensure that
gpt2 will generate some output that does
include those keywords from the original
input and because gpt2 is so bad uh it's
generally still pretty hopeless but the
chance increase from zero to maybe one
percent at this point
so the chance of generating correct
summary uh is slightly better than
before
yeah
throw logic decoding you just a little
more detail like what exactly is it yeah
so it's our there are two previous
papers one of which was not good best in
paper Minor Detail
um done by undergrad student as the
first author by the way at the time at
least and so it's a search algorithm
that's built on Bim search
but you need to be a little bit
strategic about beams because you want
to make sure that diverse patterns are
covered otherwise you are stuck with a
very narrow beam and so that's the gist
of it but in the paper we actually
support the full cmf form uh the
conjunctive normal form based logic
constraints so but here you know you
don't need that much of uh logic
constraints per se so the paper actually
the method is uh uh serves more use
cases than what we actually do here what
we actually do here on the other hand is
like a much faster re-implementation of
the original paper for the purpose of uh
this over generation and filtering that
we need to do
okay so and then
um
students came up with a real interesting
idea so they had this intuition that
gpt2 will summarize better if we ask it
to summarize its own output as opposed
to human text
so they designed some left contacts in
order to prompt gpt2 to generate bunch
of sentences and
um by the way summarizing this part uh
in a meta sense there's actually more to
this but we do try different things and
we found that if we actually just try to
generate a lot of continuation and then
find some pairing between already
generated the text then your chance of
uh discovering the correct summarization
pair increases almost up to 10 percent
so uh this is um a bit uh totally
unexpected the finding just because
we're trying to do something so hopeless
so we accidentally discovered that but
anyhow so the overall framework goes to
something like this so we start with
gpt2 and then we generate lots of
candidate summaries and we are gonna
filter that which I'm gonna explain in a
bit to make this summarization data set
once you have this summarization data
set that's a high quality enough and a
scale the rest is pretty straightforward
because supervised learning almost
always works well so for the filter
basically it's like a three layer filter
that has lentil filter because sometimes
the summary doesn't summarize much other
than removing one word that's not good
enough we also have a diversity filter
just to have more more diverse language
patterns about the most important one is
this intelliment filter so we have
off-the-shelf nli model which is natural
language inference that tells you
whether a sentence is intelled from
another sentence or another or
contradicts or none of the above so a
summary should be entailed from the
original document and so we use this
intent this analy filter is not perfect
so it's not perfect but we could use it
in an aggressive manner to ensure that
the resulting summary is likely to be a
good summary and we also accidentally
realize that actually we can generalize
this to paraphrasing as well because for
paraphrasing it's almost like you need a
bi-directional entailment and so we can
generate lots of paraphrasing high
quality data set this way as well
all right so
yeah
entailment like you don't contradict to
it and things like that so this is done
by humans or is this also notified
oh that's automatic and that's based on
existing off-the-shelf nli model that is
a supervised model so which I supervised
on tens of thousands of examples where
you says interment not Intel month or
actually more like in common to
contradiction none of the above the data
sets for that yeah there's a data set
for that which uh yeah I was closing
over that so there's a famous data set
called SNL stand for the nli and
multimodal analyte that you know of
course Chris Manning and others worked
on uh there's that and then we have uh
my group also has some other data set
called wangni
where we have gpt3 to generate examples
and then have humans to validate uh so
uh that's that's a different story but
you can use any of the above but we used
a letter
but in that case by the gpt3 it's not
capable of generating correct analy
examples so
Maybe
if you can but at the time we tried
um not as much
it was too noisy to be useful without
humans actually sitting down and
annotating all of them
uh so here we ended up training T5 a
larger size this is even smaller than
the GPT to excel by the way it's not
even a billion parameter model uh and in
fact we can do this for multiple
iterations we there's no reason to study
and after one iteration the student can
become the teacher for the Next
Generation student and then repeat this
just like human life
um so then we named our data set as dim
sum
uh it has 3.4 million samples and then
the resulting model is in pretty Steel
in this Co in this particular so on our
in our own data set we don't have a
human envelope
I mean maybe we do have a human in the
loop in the sense that we as a human
design the best pipeline but
as far as a filter it's all automatic
yeah we didn't do the paper specific Neo
notation uh whatsoever
is there any filters on the right hand
side of the picture
oh I say sorry the filter is here but um
it's uh too small to notice I realized
yeah so the filter wasn't there but it
just uh we're trying to say that uh we
can repeat this multiple times
technical detail so for a T5 large model
isn't it already initialized with
summarization being trained in the
appreciating process
yeah so it probably was we kind of liked
the sick to seek aspect of it I suppose
we could have just stick to gpt2 as is
but it allowed us to have even smaller
model is part of the reason but if you
just use a T5 off-the-shelf is still you
will not necessarily get as good
performance as we or editor actually
um I think compared to GPT 3 T5 I
I think it's worse
at summarization please correct me if
I'm wrong
huh
of the filter itself the in domain so
that varies over in domain you know
within the uh for for its own training
data style examples the showtime models
are about like you know could be like
beyond the 90 percent
but for out of the domain cases it can
be quite a bit worse
so maybe I I don't know poor podcast
like 70 Sasha do you want action I've
given some of these I don't think it's
T5 I'm talking about I don't think it
was it was free training with
summarization yeah I wasn't yeah thank
you for clarifying yeah
two variants of two by
two five because one is T5
free trading mixture didn't clean
summarization and there's T 5.1.1 which
is what everyone should use which was
only trained unsupervisedly so whether
the base model that you used was trained
on summarization depends on whether you
use T5 or T5 foot 1.1
sure okay that's too good to know
we're jumping is kind of crazy yeah
thank you anywho so this is a little bit
reminiscent of reinforcement learning
actually the special variety of it
called the self imitation or expert
iteration depending on which RL group I
talked to they use a different
terminology but it's basically the same
thing which is glorified renaming of a
supervised learning in some sense that
allows the model to explore its own you
know summarization exploration and then
have this reward Network which in our
case is the filter that tells you
whether it's a good summary or not and
then you do supervised training on your
good experiences so in essence it's an
imitation self imitation learning
um so here's some example
so we're gonna summarize this text uh
which says while we will be looking
across all parts of the new of The
Newsroom at the end of the redundancy
program we expected there will be
significantly fewer editorial management
video presentation and suction writer
roles the publisher is quoted as a
saying in an internal note so our model
summarize that as uh we're looking to
reduce the number of stuff in The
Newsroom the publisher said in an
internal note whereas gpt3
first of all it doesn't look like much
of a summarization compared to the
original length this is a typical uh the
GPT 30 sometimes it doesn't summarize
much and then it added
a bit of a information that you know may
or may not be correct entirely depending
on how you scrutinize the original text
I should know gpt4 is really good I
don't think this method can be gpt4
which by the way we don't know exactly
what happened uh with their tuning so I
we don't even know like how to compare
but anyhow
um
you know one practical question though
is that I said we did uh summarize a
synthetic text as opposed to human text
and so we found that it actually
generalized well
um on the data set that is actually
written by humans for the purpose of
Downstream evaluation uh in fact
um yeah it doesn't do better than the
model trend on human human supervision
data on other domains uh so more
experiments in the paper and truly more
diverse it's in part because uh sorry
it's important because we enforce the
diversity in our filter and just to
ensure that we have a lot of a more
abstractive summarization That
instructive civilization
okay so the last video is going to be
about some paradoxes I promised earlier
that we're going to come back to some
common sense related stuff
um so GPT forecast the bar exam and then
uh Joshua Benjo says we have existential
risk and AI januku says AI is not as
smart as a dog so it's almost like
everything everywhere all that wants a
situation
so in that context I'm gonna just throw
in that maybe we have a common sense
paradox uh I like making the knowledge
of the dark matter in the sense that
maybe there's a lot more Dark Matter
than we anticipate
um and so you know some people uh are
excited about the capabilities of gbt
forum you know report that oh theory of
mind they may have spontaneously emerged
and then you know for anything like this
there's always like a counter argument
that uh no you know it's it's uh maybe
it's not as uh robust as one may have
expected so by the way for this paper uh
the 28 so many complex examples may have
been very similar to what the
pre-training data uh included whether
it's you know tomorrow
covered heat uh Disturbed the examples a
little bit and you know realize that the
models are not as robust so I have my
own version of it so gpt3 as of last
year was not able to do the classical
theory of mind so Alice and Bob saw
apple is on the table in the kitchen
always left in the kitchen
Bob in the meanwhile I move the apples
to the cabinet so there are two
locations two people this is very close
and you ask this question and gpt3 used
to say in the cabinet which is the
lateral location and it's the wrong
answer
so but that's also last year
so this year gpt4 is able to answer it
correctly so you know the first location
is the correct answer but it may have
relied a little bit overly on the fact
that usually this is a bit of a trick
question where the correct answer tends
to be the first location so out of
curiosity I will switch the order of the
last two sentences in the story
um and then you know I try the different
versions and uh gpt4 kind of sticks to
the first one but I mean if you try to
add a little bit more hint to it you
know the language
like while uh you know Alice didn't look
uh maybe I would answer it correctly so
you know some people say that yeah you
have to ask these questions more
politely to gpt4
um but um in any case the thing is
humans you know even if you ask not
politely enough are usually able to do
this job better than uh GPT for the
house and for this particular paper with
allenser joining Berkeley soon
um we design all this different variants
where maybe there are more like three
people three containers or how about
four containers and these were designed
the before charge apt or GPT four times
so the paper was written originally for
gpt3 later we added just this GPT for
performance and sometimes you know it's
a really good sometimes it's a little
bit more varied
um
and then there's this Ted Talk in which
I did this example of trying closing uh
you know okay this is psychophysics with
earlier we had discussion about you know
how much physical knowledge it was
listening so let's ask so I asked this
question uh April this year I left to
five close to Gerald in the sun it took
them five hours to dry completely how
long would it take to dry 30 clothes and
GPT Ford back then said the 30 hours but
of course you know these public examples
are gone very fast
so as of John 18 this is for my cvpr
keynote I ask a different question
because the previous question is solved
so it's an almost same question but
slightly phrase differently like how
long so if it takes 10 hours to drive
five close how long will the tectonic
close to dry if you try my original
version with different numbers than gpt4
you know gets a correct if I ask this
way at the time of June uh 18 it was
incorrect uh so at that keynote I said
oh this kind of looks like our lhf
guacamole game situation but of course
this question is is also gone so if you
try this today you're going to get the
correct answer so yesterday I knew that
by the way I knew that I didn't try any
other question until last night I
thought I'm gonna try a different one
how about this one suppose it takes
three hours to dry a short and five
hours to dry a pair of pants in the Sun
so I added of irrelevant you know object
into the phrase and it says there you go
six hours again so
um what I'm trying to tell you is this
by the way and then I saw a few days ago
Jeremy Howard says Ah you have to ask
the custom you have to start with this
custom prompt otherwise you don't so in
which you should you know Prime the
model that you are uh you know
regressive language whatever but really
on that reasoning and you know it's
motivated a little bit more
so I tried and indeed the behavior
changes but the final answer is still
yeah
if you try or feel you know not even a
few weeks are down probably will get
fixed again but that really takes you so
far
the thing is this you didn't need to do
any other HF on yourself on this like
you you just know the answer you've
never seen these examples before you
just know the answer so how does this
work is my question I'm just so curious
how did we do that that uh you know
Transformers that amazing GPT for that
can even pass the barges up that I
cannot
I'm not able to do so there's something
really mysterious about the whole thing
so okay finally the Paradox is that it
may be that all of these are
simultaneously true in some version so
common sense is Trivial for humans hard
for machines but at the same time you
know both Terror said that common sense
is not so common even among humans and
then llms do acquire best amount of
Common Sense knowledge there's nothing
quite like gpt4 that can provide as much
of a common sense prior knowledge yet
maybe yamlukun does have a point in some
ways so
uh more of that's Paradox I think this
came up only maybe uh aliasha mentioned
this earlier that is basically contrary
to traditional assumptions uh higher
level reasoning might be easier for
computers than lower level perceptual
stuff so it might be to the point that
maybe uh language is easier than vision
and we might have AGI even without
embodiment that matches gold level
capabilities who knows so
ideal part of the challenge though there
is that we don't have a really good data
set or even pre-training objective
compared to llms so whenever something
amazing happens I see that there's a bit
of this data Innovation that comes to a
play which was basically the case where
the textbook is all you need as well as
the impossible distillation that we saw
earlier so there's this uh more actions
going on about how to find the data set
lastly super quickly briefly General
paradoxes so this is like made of stuff
from my group that we're working on it
might be that um
for AI generation is easier than
understanding
um compared to how it is for humans that
you know Dali 2 is able to generate a
lot of stuff while state-of-the-art
division models are not able to see what
the model is able to AI can generate and
so forth
um I actually have a little bit more
concrete reasons as to why I think that
way but since now I'm running out of the
time I'll just skip all of this and say
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
assumptions that there's only one place
on the clothesline for a shirt right
then it's reasoning would be completely
correct
that's like what it's missing is this
facial knowledge you know okay
clothesline typically has room for
multiple shirts yeah
yeah but the same question gpt4 will
give you that kind of like uh reasoning
yeah oh it really depends on how much
space you have and oftentimes when it
does give you correct answer it might be
invoking that kind of reasoning for me
it's a little bit surprising why after
you know and then so I I thought it
solved it it's like the problems are
gone gone and then
um I ask you know different to the
phrase the question and it's like back
to the original
uh mistake mode and it's quite really
curious why why isn't this happening
like how does this work is there even a
solution around this I don't know it
feels just hard yeah yeah I mean
following this girl's question uh I
think a lot of times models have
assumptions towards based on what they
make a certain guess or decision making
and then for human we also have such
assumptions so far it seems that the
common ground for humor and the Machine
are not aligned so if there's a way
instead of just different way of
prompting if we just explicitly tell the
assumptions that we have in our mind
whether that's itself the
paradox
more like yeah like the first the first
to explain what you know how drying
Works in physics
and we can only take one shirt at one
time so it takes six hours to do two or
so yeah so I mean so that's more like
let's try to solve this fundamental
challenge through better smart uh like
Innovative prompt engineering I do
Wonder also you know can there be yes
something entirely different I don't
know the answer but I do wonder if there
may be uh entirely different solution
around the base
are there any textbooks on common sense
that what could you say surely this must
have been written not quite in the sense
that I guess a psych is one version of
you know trying to uh write down all
these Common Sense rules that
um uh in arguability them cannot very
well and then you know I also try to
build some such version of it but
through natural language description and
you know I tend to view that as some
kind of a textbook for com
um AI common sense and learning but it's
not broadly enough it's not natural
enough you know it
I kind of feel like humans
um so I I like getting some inspiration
from cognitive science humans are able
to acquire more on their own I mean they
do acquire a lot of Knowledge from
taxable or caregivers but they also
figure out quite a bit on their own and
you know I I do Wonder
um whether AI should acquire more on
their own than even relying on
pre-training at scale or not
Jacob
um could you go back to the last Paradox
the generative AI one oh yeah about uh
yeah yeah so what was this I just wanted
to see the statement of the paradox
so yeah maybe do you have intuition for
why generation is easier because I guess
my intuition is still actually the other
way around yeah I mean one so this is um
uh even within my career working on this
actively you know we're defined
understanding you know we have to uh
look at this in a different way but
um in some sense
um you know like I would say the
following um oftentimes
um non-native speakers tell me that uh
they they relied on PT for some of the
writing jobs uh and in that sense
structure PT was able to generate better
than they could but then it's it's not
quite right and you know some of the
requests in the prompting were ignored
so they need to fix it a little bit to
suit their needs in that sense it's like
understanding was a little bit lagging
behind the generation and then for uh
computer vision side so by the way for
language we tend to use one model for
both purposes which is that just like
Transformers whereas computer vision is
a little bit weird in the sense that
their generative models are different
from understanding models and for that I
kind of feel like um
I may understand generation models may
be able to generate because it
understood something at all but then
it's not able to communicate in language
well enough so that the low level
computer vision right now uh at least in
my other experiments are not reliable
enough
um
you know one good one could draw an
analogy with cryptography and say
generation is Computing a one-way
function whereas understanding isn't
working
Maybe
thank you
going back to the beginning when you're
talking about multiplication it seems
like when it's using the large language
model it's giving an intuitive guess is
that kind of how you you think about it
uh yeah I mean I think it did learn
the pre-training data does have a lot of
examples or because it also learns to
understand even like you know the
instruction we give in the scratch Pad
itself so it does have a lot of bits and
pieces understood but being able to
really accurately carrying it out is a
surprising that not as reliable as one
may have expected which it does you know
it's on one hand it's intellectually
curious on the other hand it's a bit of
an AI safe tissue as well so the right
way I'm going is that for the lar you
know humans learn language all by their
own
whereas if you want to learn how to
multiply numbers accurately that's
generally someone figured out a long
time ago and you're generally taught
that yeah so that's like very different
kind of learning models that you would
expect but the scratch Pad helps but
doesn't necessarily get you all the way
there yeah
I agree okay is there any thought to
make the scratch Pad like a more firm
learning model
so uh
obvious
and you are very instead of too much of
natural language maybe you know somehow
organized it a little bit better
and by the human intelligence
understanding you know how to prompt it
is better but still they didn't achieve
like
um
amazing out of the domain performance
it's much better than how much we were
able to do our scratch Pad is better
than the version that Google paper
previously uh used so we did improve
over what was previously done before but
it may be that there's some something
fundamentally better in that prompting
space but yeah okay last two questions
so I'm done
um yeah so so
um uh the earlier work is I already
worked to also show that with this
neural architectures oftentimes they
don't generalize especially for other
domain but then when you add for example
recursion into the neural programming
synthesis architecture then actually it
could generalize in certain cases that
can actually generalize perfectly so I'm
curious whether you have you guys have a
lot of uh whether you have tried to
actually think about how to add
incorporates recognition into either the
problem to our into this space to see
right how this actually could help to
solve problems like multiplications and
and so on yeah um so
there may be a better way to convey
recursions through scratch Pad design
that might help
um we yeah somehow this was the best we
had at the time of archiving I mean
I'm assuming that you only were
considering like a prompts engineering I
suppose architecture being included yeah
so so maybe through problem engineering
whether you could actually help it to
learn the education and and so on right
so so maybe yeah feel like we don't know
you got a slide showing this
computational graph yeah
um
so have you tried sort of just the most
naive uh kind of scratch Pad which would
be just literally showing this graph one
token at it like each node has a
sequence of tokens maybe not as much as
that we tried something that has less
natural language and more symbolic and
that didn't pan out as well as we were
the position of each token would be
fixed
it always correspond to the same note in
the graph no we didn't try what you're
envisioning no
I'm curious what happens if one tries
for fantastic talk
so we'll break for lunch to 1 30 and go
on your own there are lots of nice
places to go to in the neighborhood if
you don't know somebody
okay